and so many others have struggled with
this idea like oh oh the fans kind of
distribute my content like how do I deal
with this and our whole theory is is
like you know if you really really want
to embrace the future feel a lot of fans
to distribute this content and you'll
harness that power it's a media company
just because everything's like digital
we don't want digital content to get
worse if we'd be watching on YouTube and
so if we stop piracy we figure out a
business model they also inclusive there
because that's progressing like rich
said that's progressive media there's a
lot of a family part of the distribution
I don't think I would get to spread
right then completely be better for
whole ecosystem you believe will be
better for more bigger but this one
integration it was a speakeasy which is
kind of cool
speakeasy Ben Harper played over there
on a stage it was all illegal and they
hit alcohol in the back room that's why
they're gonna shut down and that's how
we'd have to take it so all these guys
mostly administrative staff is in this
descent of it and then we got
warehouse this is my office it's very
long and narrow kind of like an airplane
zephyr was like an homage to the z-boys
the Zephyr voice so this movie was made
by stacy peralta this is actually a
collectible poster this is the one he
took to Sundance 2001 that's you in the
picture
Thanks office in the corner there it
says we are Ryan Seacrest yes I need
some explanation you don't want to be
Ryan Seacrest you guys would like to be
writing a secret so we say we're the
Ryan Seacrest terms of tech the Ryan
Seacrest has got kind of like the guy
behind the guy he's not necessarily
trying to be the hit as much as he's
trying to draft off all the other hits
right so it's just a thing to say then
look we're not always trying to build
all the original content ourselves we're
trying to help all the great content be
great yeah the hardest-working man this
is Bob Marley transportation that's the
cool thing there's a lot of people that
actually work here live very close to
here okay so this warehouse we've got
kind of lucky because we want to be in
Venice we love Venice I live here and we
always want an office here so and we
always want to be on a bikini so as soon
as this opened up we took it but as soon
as we moved in we basically had to find
more space and just then ed rachet was
moving out which he's been there for
freaking ever since all of that
I was over here one time by this fence
and I walked over his late at night and
there was a homeless gentleman and all I
saw was his eyes peeking out from the
ground he was six feet under with his
shovel
burying something there was no one help
there it just made him and I saw him and
I see his eyes on the ground he's
looking right at me
and he's got this cello and I just
backed away things back the way I didn't
say anything
I didn't tell anyone I didn't want to
know you're breaking the silence right
now there's something going on looking
that ground
the beach bunch of bikes and surfboards
and boogie boards that stuff I think
it's in the next warehouse I'll show you
and on Monday as we go down and we have
what we call Zefram mornings at 7:30
a.m. and we play volleyball on the beach
and go paddle boarding I do not go
clear this out when we had our billion
monthly news party in December we did
that that's where it was its cascade
played my brother
he played and maybe will do it again
when we hit the 2 billion it's very cool
yeah next month